you recently
made a move from the west coast to
atlanta yeah
because she was living up in the bay
right yeah um
how has that been i mean you're saving a
lot of money on rent
i feel like moving to along with the
second business i made in my life i feel
like to move to the bay was the best
move
and then i moved to london singapore
because i felt like
not like that i feel like the big one i
always [ __ ] with man i'm always [ __ ]
debate i just feel like
i did everything i'm gonna do after like
well you that's like the babies kind of
what heated you up yeah they're gonna
always [ __ ] with me
i'm always here a little over them that
whole look
that whole side yeah i feel like i feel
like the bay is like uh
you know it's a unique place to break
out of especially considering like
you're from the south
exactly people probably even though when
they hear you
you i mean i would say yeah this kid's
from the south but i feel like
people associate you with the base so
much a lot of people probably think
you're from there
i don't even really be treating though
be true
i thought you feeling so like i don't
really be tripping